in kabul streets are full of life
markets are busy and even amusement
parks are open for visitors including
some bemused taliban fighters
this street in the afghan capital cabo
used to be closed for most afghan
citizens until recently this is where
the afghan ministry of interior used to
be and where the european union's
mission was also located that meant that
to get into the street you had to pass
several layers of security barriers
those barriers have now been taken down
as the taliban try to convey a sense of
normalcy in the capitol
but the situation here is far from back
to normal the economy is on the verge of
collapse and many afghans say they don't
know where the next paycheck is going to
come from
and it's not just the economy women's
freedoms are being taken away
the taliban have banned teenage girls
from going to school and reintroduced
harsh islamic punishments as they shot
and then hung a group of alleged
kidnappers in herat
so in many ways the reality on the
ground here in kabul is in contrast to
the messages that the taliban have been
sending
since the taliban took control in august
fighters have been patrolling the
streets toting guns and manning
checkpoints in kabul
their presence demonstrates military
might but is also way for the taliban to
convey that afghans are safe
alhamdulillah
inshallah a recent spate of attacks is
undermining that sense of security
in kabul a bomb exploded at a mosque in
early october leaving several citizens
dead no one immediately claimed
responsibility for the attack
in other parts of the country the
taliban have been struggling to contain
the threat from islamic state which has
said it was behind deadly roadside
bombings
both the taliban and islamic state want
to impose strict islamic rules on
afghanistan but have deep religious and
political differences
the taliban have been trying to portray
a moderate image
but on the ground they've reimposed
harsh punishments reminiscent of how
they used to rule the country in the
late 1990s in the western city of herat
the taliban killed four men they accused
of being kidnappers then hung them from
a public square
many afghans feared the taliban's
hardline rule especially those who worry
that it will threaten basic freedoms
women in particular have borne the brunt
of these new regulations
the taliban initially said that it would
allow women to attend school
but we've seen now that they've banned
girls from attending secondary school
and women have been sent home from
offices
in many provinces of the country women
are no longer allowed to leave the house
without a male relative
escorting them around the streets
many afghans fear that the taliban will
ban music like they did in the 1990s
[Music]
already many afghans refrain from
playing music in public and classes have
stopped at the renowned national
institute of music which was home to the
country's first all-female orchestra
as they work out how to govern the
taliban have been seeking to rule the
international community and win
diplomatic recognition however most
countries have stopped short of
officially recognizing the taliban's
government and have suspended aid
after the taliban took control the u.s
the imf and other countries also froze
afghanistan's foreign currency reserves
which the country is heavily reliant on
and that's had a huge effect on the
economy there's a lack of cash and banks
have put a strict limit on how much
money people can withdraw
that means afghans don't have enough
money to buy the food that they're used
to and they don't have enough money to
basically keep the economy going
before the taliban came to power
nearly half the population lived in
poverty
but it was rare to see scenes like this
of afghans struggling to find food
or queuing up outside atms to withdraw
cash
the un has warned of growing starvation
and pledged 1.2 billion in emergency aid
[Music]
[Music]
many people who work for the former
government have lost their jobs
unemployment is soaring and at the same
time prices of food and fuel are rising
and afghans are worried that the coming
winter is going to be a struggle
you